dans les milieux où il ya vraiment le
pouvoir il ya pas de femmes parce que
les femmes ont une forme d'intelligence
différentes de celles des hommes je suis
désolé de le dire au moment où les
femmes arrivent en politique c'est
justement le moment où le pouvoir
désertent la politique le pouvoir ne
doit pas rester seulement de la main des
hommes bien sûr que si sinon il sinon il
se dilapide c'est aux femmes de se poser
la question elles n'ont pas la même
forme d'intelligence que les hommes
elles n'ont pas la même forme d'
approche
de des choses que les hommes elle
n'incarne pas le pouvoir c'est comme ça
c'est sait il le joue dit le pouvoir
s'évapore dès qu'elle arrive les femmes
qui complètement d'après moi affolé car
elles ne savent pas qu'elles quoi faire
du pouvoir qui leur ait eu 100 qui leur
échoit pardon sans qu'elle comprenne
exactement à quoi ça correspond qu'à
chaque fois que les femmes arrivent dans
une profession en masse en général la
profession pas comment dire ceux se
déconsidère ce prolétarisés l'homme est
définie par sa capacité à protéger la
femme et l'enfant donc par la guerre
sans cela il n'a aucune légitimité ils
ne se rendent pas compte qu'à partir du
moment où ils disent plus jamais la
guerre ça veut dire plus jamais l'homme
l'homme quand il aime quand il aime il
sanctifie la femme et donc ils
n'arrivent plus à désirer en clair et
net d'amendé le soldat allemand sera le
vecteur de l'émancipation de la femme
française comment s'appelait le phallus
chez les romains fascinus les femmes
veulent être fasciné et les hommes
veulent fasciné je crois que le
féminisme en revanche est un
totalitarisme parce que le capitalisme
n'a plus besoin de producteurs en europe
et en france il a besoin que des
consommateurs qu'est ce qui est un bon
consommateur c'est la femme nous créons
des générations d'un puissant
d'homosexuels et de et de divorce il
faut trouver un moyen de limiter les
familles monoparentales les familles
monoparentales c'est donc plaît
aujourd'hui aux états unis les
républicains avec bush ont supprimé
certaines allocations aux mères seules
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que
quelque part c'est un progrès que les
hommes s'occupent de la moufle a autant
que les femmes moi je crois que c'est
une vraie catastrophe
je pense qu'une femme doit nettoyer un
enfant les
l'homme a toujours été un trade à te la
femme est elle au gibier sexuelle de
l'homme je continue à penser qu'il y à
de la violence dans leurs rapports
sexuels entre hommes et femmes on a des
magistrates qui sont pour la plupart des
femmes et qui condamne des hommes pour
des crimes sexuels et elles sont une
férocité incroyable par exemple sur
l'infidélité ils prennent leurs valises
dans les 24 heures mais je sais
extraordinary les garçons sont tétanisés
je les connais un peu mieux que vous les
politiques pas non mais moi c'est à dire